NARRATOR: Following the advice
of their eyewitness, Grandpa--
What should I look for?
NARRATOR: --the team has
found several symbols
that, according to
Martin, coincide
with the Golden Lily Code.
A pyramid, a set of box
markers next to breach six,
a pack animal trail leading to
a possible collapsed tunnel,
as well as a possible
gorilla face marker.
But the team has yet to find a
viable way inside the mountain.
To help with their
search, the LiDAR team
arrives to conduct
its aerial scan
of the 5,000 foot
mountain, and hopefully
reveal a potential opening.
Hey, guys.
Welcome to the jungle.
- How are you doing?
Good.
Yourself?
Good to meet you.
How was your ride?
Hey, nice to meet you.
We're excited to
have you guys here.
Yeah, we're all ready to go.
Absolutely.
All right, let's
get stuff done.
Jamie and his
team wrote the book
on this type of technology.
What they will show us
will be invaluable to what
we do on this mountain.
There's so many places
on this mountain
that the Japanese could have
potentially buried treasure
or brought treasure to,
and having that LiDAR
here is the key to
getting into the mountain.
NARRATOR: A sensor
with 360 degree vision
is mounted beneath the drone.
As it flies, it fires
rapid pulses of laser light
toward the ground
and then measures
how long it takes for the
light to return to the sensor.
Collecting millions of
measurements per second
enables the LiDAR to produce
a 3D map of the area.
The goal-- reveal what could
lie beneath the dense foliage.
All right.
Spinning up.
Taking off.
Right now, we're at 150 feet.
NARRATOR: When the drone
reaches its cruising altitude,
the LiDAR begins
scanning the mountain,
gathering the data
for its 3D map.
Is that a road going
across the top over there.
Yeah, that's a road.
Wow.
All right.
Ready?
Scan the whole thing.
I want to see everything.
Don't miss a spot.
I want to see where the Japanese
actually drove their trucks
or had their encampments.
Show me something really good.
I need you guys to step back.
Nice job.
Thank you.
We just used the best
technology on the planet.
And the data they
provide with their LiDAR
is going to certainly
come in handy
and help us to
find this treasure.
NARRATOR: Later that
day, back at base camp,
the LiDAR team is ready
to share their results--
a digital map of the surface
of the mountain with all
the vegetation removed.
Show us what you've got.
So this is the surface
model we have with all
the vegetation in the way.
That's a lot of vegetation.
There's a lot of it.
Holy crap.
And I'll turn off
that vegetation.
Oh, look at that!
That is sweet!
So this is the
bare earth model.
This is just ground.
That's unbelievable.
You can see all the nooks
and crannies, every elevation,
every little runoff area.
This is just awesome.
So if you think
this is impressive,
I actually took the
time to digitize
all the trails that I found.
Let me bring that up.
There she is.
Ah-ha!
Holy moley!
So there are the
trails in there.
That is more than
I even anticipated
we were going to see.
That is just unreal.
There's a hell of a lot of
trails and roads, possibly,
all over this mountain that
we couldn't see before.
The possibility of [inaudible]
treasure being here,
based on just what we're
seeing, is phenomenal.
So those trails, if there
were foot trails or footpaths,
they just go up into the
mountain and they stop.
Why would they just dead
end somewhere, especially
into the side of a hill?
This right here could
be a cave entrance.
What makes you think
that it's a cave, based
on just what we're seeing?
How the path that goes
up to it, like right here.
There's a
depression right here.
We have to go up
there and look at it
to try to really understand
what's going on there.
It looks like it's actually
the entrance way to something.
Yep, it looks like you
probably could get in there.
If there's a possibility that
there's a pathway dead ending
at a cave, I want to see it.
I'm taking Jamie,
we're going up there.
We're going to find it.